have you guys tried to think of who
would be the quintessential like first
guest
I already already got them
really I ain't gonna tell you though
I feel I feel like
a Schoolboy Q or a tiger or they're in
that room okay hey shout out to tiger
man tell him to come through that'd be a
relationship with him
you do too you hey is it Rocky you I
mean I don't have I don't have a
relationship with him you can text him
me yeah I can't text time can you DM him
I could text like why can't you DM them
you can DM them I did before no we know
we know damn
the first for the first interview oh
bruh oh we're having the first one
T-Roy I gotta put this out I'm calling
you out Memphis relationship yeah yeah
that'd be amazing my goodness man what
the [__] are you gonna go in there and
talk about you gonna cry like a little
hoe
I miss you
it's been so long
now
oh that'd be great if you guys
resurrected Last Kings in 2023 you're
the greatest you're the greatest
businessman of all time hell no why
would you need that when you got 80
running around here with Cher [__] [__]
last kids
yeah he got Avril Lavigne ain't worried
about that [__] it's over that's my
[__] got share out here boys you crazy
we on this uh swish clothing and
sorella.com
um so are you guys going to Adam's
wedding
why is this the biggest like question
everybody said I'm not going to that
[__] [__]
ain't gonna be awkward and my dirt is
awesome goddamn tickets [__] with
this [__] man I'm going look he got me
doing all type of [__] over here bro huh
I did a reverse super Uno uh Nazi nah
still go to Italy have a good time I
love Italy it's in Italy yeah
let's go to Italy's still I'm winning
we're talking about the spots we can do
some shopping hey how hilarious would it
be if you guys went to Italy during the
same time
don't let this [__] pump you up
everyone's at the same hotel and you're
like hey we're just we could drive past
the venues look
you everybody get scared I mean but if
we did go would it be a problem I feel
like y'all should go I don't but but
like we just joking now like I don't
know I got my ticket
Adam my mind might change May by May
19th this is all jokes at the end of the
day but I still look at them like a
homeboy right you feel me like if he he
can text me he just text me the other
day he could text me I could text him
and [__] like that like it ain't no bad
blood like [__] appreciate him you
know for we wouldn't even be doing what
we doing right now if he didn't put the
battery in our back so
um we always gonna have respect for him
when they come down today and thank you